car vice président de l'association des
médecins microbiologiste-infectiologue
du québec
bonsoir dr weiss bonsoir question alors
tout d'abord j'aimerais qu'on parle et
surtout que vous nous fassiez bien
comprendre qu'est ce qui se passe
actuellement avec lille de roxy
chloroquine on a permis les essais la
recherche c'est maintenant avant on a
abandonné la recherche on à me faire la
recherche la revue lancet qui a été
éclaboussée ou est-ce qu'on en est est
ce que c'est encore prometteur
l'hydroxyde chloroquine et est-ce qu'il
faut tout recommencer la du départ ok
alors on va essayer de remettre les
choses en perspective
premièrement hydroxy chloroquine n'est
pas un médicament qui a été fait pour la
cause 19 faut bien comprendre c'est un
médicament comme tous les autres qu'on
essaye actuellement qu'on a sorti d'un
tiroir et qu'on s'est dit désespéré
on va l'essayer voir si ça marche alors
il ya des gens qui ont fait des études
si vous voulez au niveau du mécanisme de
fonctionnement de la molécule et se sont
peut-être donc est ce qu'on sait il ya
eu le professeur didier raoult en france
qui a commencé à faire des études qui
ont été des études quand même c'est
relativement sérieuse pas des essais
classique qu'on voit habituellement qui
montrait peut-être qu'on certaine
efficacité qui a été critiqué quand même
il a été critiqué mais à partir de là
l'engouement est parti à l'échelle
planétaire
après ça il ya eu toute une série
d'études qui ont été faites à droite à
gauche mais jamais devant études et là
on a eu je vous dirais la politique la
science
on a eu le mélange de la philosophie de
la sociologie de tuer et qui ont fait
que finalement tout ça est venu se
mélanger dans certaines études et que
pour toutes sortes de raisons on est
arrivé à des conclusions qui étaient
très diverses
d'un côté on avait des études qui
n'utilisaient ça peut être un effet
prometteur
d'un autre côté on nous tease et ça
aucun effet du tout d'abord ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que les études qui ont
montré que l'hydroxyde chloroquine avait
une efficacité ont toujours été faites
avec un autre médicament qui est un
antibiotique qui s'appelle
l'azithromycine dont on sait qu'elle a
des propriétés anti inflammatoires pour
des problèmes pulmonaires
c'est la première chose à se rappeler la
deuxième chose à se rappeler c'est que
s'ils hydroxy chloroquine a un effet ça
va être un effet qui va être
et probablement pour les gens qui sont
pas très malade et probablement
administrés tôt dans le traitement mais
troisièmement ce qui est dommage dans
tout ça c'est qu'on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
une espèce de gâchis scientifique qui a
été teintée par toutes sortes de
d'intérêt économique politique
philosophique tout ce que vous voulez
d'un côté comme de l'autre pour essayer
de discréditer
certaines études et de montrer plus
toxiques l'euro qui ne valait rien alors
c'est la faute du lancet ce n'est pas la
première fois que lens est se retrouve
dans l'eau chaude d'ailleurs alors il ya
27 c'est important lundi est pour nous
tous les spectateurs c'est vrai que
c'était une référence pour la science
avec un comité éditorial très sérieux de
très haut niveau qui juge les travaux
oui alors c'est ça le problème c'est que
des fois des comités éthiques herriot de
très haut niveau sont pas de si haut
niveau ça puis des fois il ya des
intérêts autres qui peuvent intervenir
l'attend donc avec le 27 et je ne sais
pas la première fois que c'est déjà
arrivé dans le passé mais c'est une
vraie vie tu as même prestigieuses ou de
tap la majorité des articles qui sont
publiés sont de bonne qualité mais là il
est arrivé que les gens aussi peut-être
dans le feu de l'action
parce que c'est quelque chose de tout le
monde veut des résultats vite on ne fait
pas les je vous dirais les contrôles
qu'on fait habituellement ne fait pas
les corrections ont fait habituellement
et on publie peut-être les choses un peu
trop bas que les autres malwares ont un
peu oui
malheureusement il faut aussi savoir que
beaucoup de gens maintenant ils veulent
publier pour publier parce que comme on
dit dans le milieu scientifique il faut
publier pour essayer de d'avoir plus de
fonds d'avoir plus de recherche etc dont
il ya une course à la publication il ya
une course à avoir une certaine renommée
et tout ça malheureusement dans cette
histoire l'a fait qu' on est en train
peut-être de donner de fausses données
scientifiques à la légère
je reviens à ma question départ si vous
le permettez dr weiss je reviens à ma
question de départ est ce que il ya
encore de l'espoir est ce que c'est
encore porter l'hydroxyde eurokin est-ce
qu'on doit recommencer la recherche
oui alors il faut recommencer la
recherche il faut bien la faire mais si
l espoir ça va être pour des gens qui
vont être plus malades qui vont être en
début de leur maladie et probablement
administrés avec les roms ici
parlons encore 2,27 parce qu'une autre
étude justement qui a été publié et
celle là semblent moins controversées
concernant les outils de protection
c'est à dire le masque les gants et
caetera et c'est là qu'on s'est aperçu
que le masque selon le recensement de je
pense plus qu'une touche 872 études
on a réalisé que le match était quand
même assez efficace pour prévenir la
maladie
oui alors tout à fait dans cette une
étude beaucoup plus sérieuse parce que
s'il mettait un ali c'est à dire c'est
une étude des études c'est une étude qui
a colligé 172 études différentes et qui
à regarder l'aspect de la distanciation
physique de l'efficacité des masques et
on s'aperçoit que les masses en effet
ont une utilité très grande puisque il
diminue de façon importante le risque de
contamination
plus de 75% et et pour certains types de
match des n 95 plus de 95%
donc ce qu'on voit c'est que les masses
pour un rôle important à jouer comme la
distanciation physique on s'aperçoit que
après 1 m il ya un effet protecteur de
cette distanciation et plus on s'éloigne
plus cet effet protecteur va augmenter
non quand on dit aux gens de rester
éloignés les uns des autres et porter un
masque en plus de laver les mains qui
toujours utile lors qu'on fait c'est un
effet multiplicateur qui a un effet
protecteur certes parlez-nous
d'intervalle des surfaces parce que dans
cette méta étude justement on s'aperçoit
que c'est loin d'être prouvée comme on
le craignait au départ que les surfaces
que le virus surviennent vivent très
longtemps sur les surfaces et qui ont en
plus la trappe et en touchant aux chocs
aux comptoirs ou fruits aux légumes mais
que c'était tout à fait alors les
surfaces c'est probablement un mode de
transmission qui est improbable mais pas
impossible donc mais c'est pas un mode
de transmission qui est privilégiée
alors qu'est ce qu'on sait sur le sur
play surface et qu'on ne sait que le
virus peut survivre quelques jours oi et
où quelques heures ça dépend des types
de surface mais ce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est que est ce que le virus qui survit
peut être transmis donc on n'a pas fait
encore ce lien là donc ce qu'on sait sur
les surfaces c'est que oui le virus peut
survivre mais oui ça peut se transmettre
mais si ça le fait c'est probablement
quelque chose qui est rare et pas très
efficace et qui est pas le mode de
transmission qui vous rêviez
la torride 19 donc est-ce qu'il faut
baisser notre garde relativement aux
surfaces est ce que ces cinq saleuses et
non pas du tout parce que c'est encore
de la contamination important quand je
vous ai expliqué c'est l'ensemble des
mesures lavage des mains porter hamas et
la distanciation physique d'un session
comme si je si je touche une surface de
la compagnie et vous la touchez tout de
suite après vous chez votre visage ou
risqué aussi poèmes à la doctoresse
merci infiniment ce soit un très bon
week-end
on se reparle très bientôt au revoir au
revoir